working with u.s politics we're joined
now in the studio by labour's shadow
international trade secretary emily
thornbury thank you very much for being
with us
um we just heard sanji javid there
talking about donald trump damaging
democracy about the fragility of
democracy
what's your reaction to the fact that
the current president doesn't seem to be
accepting the result of the election i
don't think anybody can be surprised
i think that it's very much the sort of
pattern of behavior that he indulges in
and actually he's told us himself hasn't
he for some time that this is what he's
going to do
um i think what's important is that we
all stand united
those of us that are interested in
democracy and
supporters of western democracy in
particular this is the biggest uh
democracy in what in in the west um and
to have the sitting president saying
that the the result isn't valid
is is very damaging indeed and so i
think it's very important we all speak
with one voice on this
and we're quite clear that there has
been a
an election there has had a huge turnout
that all the votes have been
counted and president biden is president
biden
you of course haven't exactly held back
with your remarks about donald trump in
the past you've described him as racist
as a sexual predator you said he should
be treated like a bully i mean
it's not most destroyed an asteroid of
awfulness i think which was turned into
a cartoon in the united states
yes well that's what he is and i have
personally always thought
that the the government had a choice
when he was elected they could have
spent their time holding his hand and
sucking up to him and hoping to get
something
some crumbs from the table and how has
that worked we have got nothing from
that
you know we haven't got i mean they're
still putting tariffs
on whiskey you know because of a
long-standing dispute on
aircraft you know we're supposed to be
doing a trade deal and yet we can't even
get these punitive tariffs off
we can't even get the killer of poor
harry dunn
you know back to britain in order to
face our justice
you know all of these things that we
knew the prime minister has gone
personally to his good friend
donald trump and asked for these things
why do you have gotten a good friend
and why do you think the government
sucked up to him well i think what they
have done
i i think they genuinely what is the
evidence for that what they sacked up to
him
that they're good friends well they held
his hand you know the prime minister
held his hand on a number of a
previous prime minister we've heard
we've we've seen the way in which
in which uh they have never criticized
they have never said
that they disagreed with him even during
the election itself we've heard them
being merely mouthed
and not set and not standing up but
isn't that it's a democratic election
isn't it yes
you wouldn't expect people to be to be
criticizing a candidate while a
democratic election is going on with
none by most important allies also if
you look at
for example in policy terms you know
that there's quite a lot of clear water
between boris johnson and donald trump
isn't there on things
like trade on things like iran or things
like climate change
okay so where do you want me to start so
let's start with yes i understand during
an election you know it would be wrong
for foreign powers to be intervening for
heaven's sake
but once the election has finished and
once the votes are being counted and you
have the president of the united states
saying that the visit
saying the vote is not legitimate then i
think that
that our prime minister should have
stood up along with the german foreign
minister
along with the irish prime minister and
all kinds of international figures and
said
this is not the behavior that we expect
this is wrong so i think that's that
i think that there there of course there
are some policy differences
uh between britain and the united states
and thankfully now
we are going to have a president who
will be more in line with our
policies and with what we think is the
right way of behaving
but there has been a general approach a
populist approach
from boris johnson which i think he has
had in common with donald trump and that
is why they have
you know they have had such a close
friendship that's why they have been so
mutually congratulatory
you know and it'll be very difficult i
think it's not impossible but it'll be
very difficult to move from that to
being close to joe biden i understand
that
do you think that obviously you know
there are many
valid criticisms that people make about
donald trump but at the same time you
know he has
when you look at international affairs
he's reset the relationship with china
he's
tried to make approaches to north korea
and
he's also of course not started any wars
like some other u.s presidents that you
could think of has he really been so bad
i think that he has been a disrupter i
think that he
for example on north korea what does he
do he marches in there
he says he's going to he's going to sort
things out he he brings us to the edge
of war
do you remember how anxious we all were
as to what an earth was going to happen
next
and then he pulls back and thinks that
it can all be done by way of a
friendship and yet nothing has been
achieved
and look at the amount of time that
we've wasted and what are the north
koreans been doing in the meantime
we have seen the way in which he
withdrew support from the kurds
who were you know working with the west
um
you know and and and just basically left
them to their fate
uh he has been a disrupter he has
undermined international institutions
look what he's done to the who
look at the fact that we keep talking
about the world trade organization the
world trade organization
doesn't have a court that properly works
because the appeal court
doesn't have enough judges because
donald trump keeps
saying he's not prepared to have the
judges whose names are put forward so we
don't have an appeal court on the wto
so the conservatives say oh it's fine we
can go
into a world you know run by the run by
the world trade organization and yet the
world trade organization is
fundamentally disrupt you know
dysfunctional because of the behavior of
donald trump amongst other things
no he has not been a good thing for the
international
world you know rules-based order and now
we have with joe biden somebody
who does understand that we need to work
together it is not a question of america
first
it's a question of the world first and
the only way that's going to work is if
we work together
you um clearly much happier with the
idea of abide in presidency and a trump
presidency i don't think that would
surprise anybody and but i just wonder
with your
shadow international trade secretary hat
on are you concerned
that actually joe biden is going to be
tougher to do a trade deal with
post-brexit than donald trump who said
that because of the special relationship
britain would be at the front of the
queue
so i think that what we have to do is we
have to kind of unpick this a little bit
because donald trump and and boris
johnson may have been talking about a
trade deal
but there have been all kinds of
problems in reality with trying to get a
trade deal together so
if we talk about you know agriculture
then when we have looked at it we have
realized that we haven't wanted to have
agricultural products come into britain
that are produced in a completely
different way but do you think joey
barnett will be easier no no all i'm
saying is that the reality is
is that actually getting a fun a an
all-singing all-dancing trade deal is
something that takes
many years and is quite you know quite
complex and quite difficult to
to put together i think i think that the
right approach would be this
would be for us to say yes of course we
want to increase trade
and one of the things that we now have
in common with the with the new
president
is our commitment to climate change now
we should be
working with them in order to be able to
to
tackle climate change together and
actually there are all sorts of
opportunities in terms of
of jobs and growth in that let's work
together on that
um but let's also then as the next thing
is make sure that we have a proper deal
with the european union
with whom we do half of our trade and
that we're not undermining the good
friday agreement
and then we can move on to working with
the united states further on
other areas where we could increase
trade at the moment we do 18
of our trade with the united states we
do 48 of our trade with the european
union we have to kind of keep these
things
in that sort of perspective okay and now
while i've got
you i'm keen to talk to you about jeremy
corbyn being suspended from
the labour party for saying that
allegations of anti-semitism were
overstated of course it comes after that
report by the
equality and human rights watchdog that
said that labour had acted unlawfully
have you spoken to him since then i
haven't spoken to jeremy i'm
i'm probably going to be seeing him
today obviously because it's remembrance
sunday
but no i have not spoken to him directly
you of course were in the shadow cabinet
with jeremy corbyn a time when you were
all going around knocking on doors
giving interviews saying that he should
be in number 10.
and now you're saying it's right for him
to be suspended from
labour do you regret being in the shadow
cabinet with him well
the first thing is is that i am not
expressing an opinion about
with the disciplinary process in
relation to jeremy because it has always
been my
firmly held view that it is not for
politicians to make decisions on this
front what we have always been told
is that it should be done by the party
or it should be done on an arm's length
basis
the the ehrc report has also
specifically said that politicians
should keep out of this
and that it should be done in an
independent way so whatever my private
views are about this i'm not going to
express them
on national television okay but do you
regret being in the shadow cabinet
campaigning for jeremy corbyn to be
prime minister when at the time we knew
about
allegations of the way labour was
handling anti-semitism
so i think that i it's quite clear i'm
on the record i was on record at
party conference in the media and i
think that some of these
uh books that have been written about
what was going on behind the scenes
make it clear that i was saying in
private what i was saying in public so
if you thought
that then why why were you staying in
the shadow cabinet because
because i felt that it was a struggle
but that we were going in the right
direction
so that you know the processes had taken
too long to improve
but they were getting better i didn't
know the extent
of the issues in terms of the
interference of jeremy's office
with the disciplinary process i didn't
know the extent of that because i'm
obviously i'm not on the nec
okay i'm not involved in the background
stuff but i knew that we were making
progress
it was a struggle okay but it was the
right place for me to be was to be there
making sure that we were going in the
right direction uh we're at time but i
just want to squeeze one last thought in
we're in coronavirus lockdown yeah if
you knew your neighbours were breaking
the rules having some people over for
dinner would you report them to police
no but i would talk to them about it
okay fair enough
emily thornbury thank you very much for
being on the programme today thank you